a picturesque city on the Tennessee
River deep in the American South it
doesn't take long to see what matters
most in Chattanooga it seems there's a
church on every single corner and many
in between - but not far behind religion
right now is the automobile this is more
than just America's love for everything
on four wheels this is about a famous
brand from faraway Germany Volkswagen
the people's car now is Chattanooga's
car - VW's ultra high-tech production
plant has become a big source of pride
here but for now for all the sunshine
it's under a cloud and fee W is in
crisis mode imposing a media blackout
not just on its own operations but on
its network of suppliers - but for
everybody else the scandal is the talk
of the town so we spent a couple of days
getting a sense of what people here
think we spoke to The Economist working
out what all this means for the local
economy - the workers who are worried
their jobs are in danger - the
politician who doesn't like the labor
unions getting involved and - the
activists worried about the millions of
dollars of sweetness that the
politicians gave VW let's start with the
prognosis from University of Chattanooga
economist Bruce Hutchinson I think there
will be some loss of jobs I will be
surprised if VW headquarters in Germany
doesn't make decisions to primarily keep
its employment level at its factories
and business locations in Germany I
think most of any reduction in
employment will be spread among
production facilities through the rest
of the world including Chattanooga all
of that is keeping this man awake at
night Mike Cantrell is head of the
United Auto Workers Union in Chattanooga
he's come to meet a couple of colleagues
at their temporary base near the VW
plant
it's temporary because Volkswagen hasn't
formally recognized their union yet
after they narrowly failed to win the
backing of the plants workers that
leaves them feeling vulnerable if the
axe does start to fall I just know that
we need recognition especially for times
like this
if we would have had a work council in
place and a union in place by this time
we would at least had an ideal that if
things need to be adjusted or tightened
for a period of time we would know the
process we would not know but we would
not just have an unknown single income
household I have two daughters that I
try to support and I definitely have to
start thinking about changes if
something doesn't happen soon but I'm in
the meantime we'll support VW a hundred
percent and I just ask them do the same
it brought a big weight and you with
that in mind you're gonna have the fear
people feel like they're stepping on
eggshells and they're making
preparations to get all the employment
they're thinking about their families VW
says it's open to union recognition but
even that is highly controversial at the
American South where unions have
struggled to gain a foothold Republican
state senator Todd Gardenhire says
unions don't protect jobs they stifle
the economy he says the current crisis
that VW is no reason to change his mind
why is the UAW want to come in here they
got great benefits they got a brand new
plants they got safety
they've got companies trying to do the
best for employees they got to compete
the community wants new best employees
and there's another political factor to
throw in the mix Gardenhire supported
the hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of incentives that were given to
VW to build and expand the plant all
those taxpayers dollars now at risk if
worse came to worse then the bow swag
won't have to pay us back the incentives
that the that were put up of course
we've got the land we've got the
building and everything that's cool we
got collateralize pretty good
but others do see cause for concern like
the taxpayers activist Helen burns sharp
she worries that Chattanooga drove an
unequalled bargain as david to VW's
Goliath David is not as wealthy and
David is not as big and David is more
vulnerable and and David is operating on
faith largely here and these agreements
that that that Goliath is going to do
what they said they were gonna do a
small city that's tied its fate to that
of a giant corporation as another day
passes here in Chattanooga it's people
are waiting for VW's next move